hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
on Game of Thrones we're going to get to
meet the sand snakes for the first time
they're going to be a little bit
different on this show than they're on
the book so what I'm going to do is do a
breakdown of their history
in the books and then talk about some of
the minor changes the show is making
just like a lot of other characters that
they end up changing from the books what
I think is going to happen is is they'll
give them story from characters that
they cut out so just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far so in the books there
are eight total sand snakes they're the
bastard daughters of Oberyn Martell and
various women the show is only doing
three of them Obara Nymeria and tyene on
the show Nymeria and tyene are both the
daughters of ilaria sand that's a big
change in the books in the books ilaria
is the mother of the four youngest sand
snakes ones that are like really really
young they don't get a whole lot of time
in this story they just you know they
run around and play in the water gardens
it's the oldest sand snakes that really
contribute to the plot Obara sand is the
oldest so on the show she's actually
probably one of the least changed
characters she's still the daughter of a
mystery prostitute they never say who
when she was old enough he came to claim
her he threw a spear down into the sand
and says you choose the spear which you
know represented a life with him or you
choose your mother and she chose the
spear all eight daughters are bastards
but they all have very different
personalities
Obara is the most militaristic she
teaches very martial pursuits in the
book she's around like Jaime Lannister
Cersei Lannister age the show has
changed that just because it's aged all
the characters of Jaime Cersei Lannister
you know nearing their 40s although on
the show based on the actress that they
cast it seems like she is closer to her
30s late 20s maybe because Obara is such
a warrior she uses a number of weapons
very effectively most notably the spear
and the whip the same type of spear that
Oberyn Martell used but because you know
the show wants to distinguish the
characters it's giving each of the sand
snakes that it's doing a separate weapon
that is to say it's kind of showcasing
different specialties for each of the
characters which is true the books to
each of the sand snakes have their own
specialties but because they're
simplifying the characters just a little
but you know we might not see some of
those moving down the list is Nymeria
sand she's like the next oldest sand
snake this actress right here on the
show her mother is actually a noblewoman
from old volantis remember that was the
place where Tyrion just got bogarted by
Jorah Mormont Oberyn Martell's famous
for having sex with like half the world
so she's just more proof that he has
children all over the world there a
couple big differences between hurt and
Obara sand in the books
Nymeria is is much more elegant more
refined and she uses different weapons
Obara is like the rough and tumble sand
snake she's just as likely to get into
like a drunken fist fight
Nymeria is a little more calculating a
little little more withdrawn she's also
said to be one of the most beautiful
sand snakes you could say that's a
matter of opinion on the show but
jessica henrik very beautiful in the
trailers they've shown her using the
whip you know whipping the bucket off of
that person said that's buried in the
sand in the book she actually uses
daggers which it looks like they've
given to tyene sand so you can see how
like they've given each of the sand
snakes their own type of weapon to be
awesome with moving further down the
list is tying sand she's the daughter of
Oberyn Martell in a mystery septa
there's a whole lot of theories that she
might secretly be a waynwood and have
some sort of claim on the Eyrie but that
that's just a wild theory that hasn't
been debunked yet the show isn't going
to be doing any of that in the context
of the books her mother was accepted
near Highgarden it just talks about her
crossing the Mandor rêveur with Oberyn
to visit her mother once in the Mandor
runs through the reach on the show it
looks like she'll be using daggers a lot
you could say Nymeria is daggers maybe
maybe she just borrowed them from her in
the books she is the expert of poisons
that Oberyn Martell was so moving down
the list so sand snake number four we're
getting into like sand snakes that the
show is not doing Sorella sand is the
daughter of Oberyn Martell and a woman
from the Summer Isles so far the show
hasn't traveled directly to the Summer
Isles we might see that in the future
though it's way down here so you can see
why we haven't seen it yet most of our
time on the show has been spent way
further north I know a lot of you are
really hoping to see the southern
continent at some point if we do go
there we would definitely see the Summer
Isles just because it's so close really
it just depends on which characters the
show is going to do so moving down the
list we have the four sand snakes that
are the daughters of ilaria sand in the
books we're not going to see any of
these characters because al aureus and
they kind of give the Irian Martell
storyline and made two of the older sand
snakes or daughter so you can see
they've changed a lot of that but in the
books the oldest of all aureus children
is Elias and named after oberyn's sister
of course she said to be really fond of
horses and jousting imagine a really
tiny version of Brienne
urging on a horse there actually is some
president for some really you know
badass women in recent memory in Game of
Thrones history Lyanna Stark was
actually supposed to be a pretty decent
fighter remember she looked like Arya
Stark or Arya Stark looks like her so
the fact that Arya is going to be
training with weapons kind of pays
honored to Liana's memory although Arya
never knew her the next oldest sand
snake Isabella then Doria in-law Reza
all the sand snakes in the books and on
the TV show are bastards but they do
have varying degrees of noble blood when
I say that I mean on their mother's side
with the exception of maybe Obara sand
whose mother was a the show has it
really explains a lot but ilaria sand is
actually the bastard daughter of Lord
Harmon ruler he's one of the noble
houses sworn to house Martell just like
say the Karstarks are sworn to the
Starks but it looks like the show might
not be doing Lord Harmon or older so it
might not go into her backstory in that
way in the books Harmon actually
accompanied Oberyn Martell to King's
Landing so we would have seen him in
season four if the show is going to do
him here's my big question for you guys
you know which sand snake on the TV show
are you most looking forward to I mean
it Obara seems like the most badass one
but because of some of the changes they
made it seems like they're all going to
be badass they're like a group of
characters that can't help but make a
mess of things at least that's the way
they look so I think that they'll be
safe too season 6 I do think there's
going to be a big WTF death in the the
door--and storyline but I don't think
it's going to be any of the sand snakes
it just seems like the characters who
always make a mess of things have the
best chance of surviving just because
they're more interesting you could point
to Oberyn Martell as someone that makes
a mess of things and he died within the
span of a season but I feel like the
show was just putting him forward as
almost being invincible and that's
usually when it pulls the rug out from
under you the minute someone you know
cackles in like comic book villainy and
seems to invincible usually that's when
they're getting ready to go down be you
guys can let me know you know which
character is part of this giant Dorne
storyline wherever they might be from do
you think is going to die before the end
of the season based on the number of
episodes we have left there's only a
certain amount of time for them to do
like big WTF deaths usually by the time
we hit episode four or five each season
is like is it really when stuff starts
going crazy Doran hands down I think is
going to be one of the most interesting
new places that the story is gone it's
just a whole new group of people that we
haven't spent three or four years with
already fresh meat for the grinder so as
we go along this season if there's any
specific Dorne or house martell related
story that you guys want me to do a
bonus video for just let me know don't
forget tonight is a new round of the
giveaway so be sure to subscribe to get
my episode video I'll post it after the
episode airs if you guys have been using
HBO now let me know what your experience
has been like I've actually been using
it to watch the season it's actually
been pretty stable it hasn't crashed
like HBO GO did last year so it's
actually been really nice so while you
guys wait for me to post that episode
video tonight you can click here for
last week's episode and you can click
here to learn all about the history of
Winterfell thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]